lying disgraced Republican Congressman
George Santos also known to many as
George Anthony devolder Santos George
devolder Anthony devolder Anthony Santos
and all I think that covers most of the
permutations
he has been arrested and is in federal
custody as we speak charged with 13
different criminal counts many
Republicans have wanted this guy out for
a while but it wasn't really clear they
had the whole party behind them and so
they kind of said listen we have a
process I don't know if we really have
the votes or whatever and they kind of
shut up about it and it to a degree it
went away
you then had other Republicans who very
much want to get this guy out it wasn't
clear they had a path to do it before
these charges maybe now they do what do
Republicans do now I don't know but
we'll be watching it and delightful news
to wake up to